after facebook's oversight board backs
the company's ban on donald trump
democrats call for more
the biden administration keeps playing
politics with covid and kamala harris
makes out with her husband
through a mask i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a reminder a few decades
ago private citizens used to be you know
private well the internet changed all of
that because think of all the things
you've browsed searched for
watched tweeted now imagine all of that
data being crawled through and collected
and aggregated by third parties into a
permanent record
your record that is why to keep my data
private when i go online i turn
to express at vpn did you know there are
hundreds of data brokers out there and
their sole business is to buy and sell
your data the worst part they don't have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent
one of those data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip to
uniquely identify you and your location
both expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted
through an encrypted server my ip
address is masked every time i turn
express
vpn on i'm given a random ip address
shared by other express vpn customers
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to identify me and harvest my
data the best part is how easy
expressvpn is to use
no matter what device you're on phone
laptop smart tv all you have to do is
tap one button
to get protected so if like me you
believe that your data is your business
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn on the market that's get three
expressvpn.com3
months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
go to expressvpn.com ben to
learn more alrighty so the big story of
the day continues to be
that facebook has maintained its ban on
donald trump so donald trump as you'll
recall was banned on january 7th from
facebook as well as youtube as well as
twitter
as well as instagram pretty much
everywhere there's a blanket band put on
the sitting president of the united
states because he said a bunch of stuff
that people didn't like it was not clear
how it had violated the rules in any
substantial way
certainly no more than ayatollah
khamenei or louis farrakhan
or a wide variety of other deplorables
around the world but
donald trump was banned because the tech
bros decided that he was innately
dangerous and therefore he had to be
banned until after the election
or until after the inauguration and then
they just were like okay well i guess
we'll just
leave him banned well the facebook
oversight board made two decisions
yesterday one was was the original ban
appropriate
they said yes based on the idea that
trump had said positive things about
people doing violence
which again is a is an odd standard
considering the entire democratic party
came out in strong defense of people
doing violence and looting during the
summer last year
and continue by the way to defend a wide
variety of criminals
as long as they are in some sort of
tussle with the police and then the
facebook oversight board
did what facebook didn't want them to do
and they tossed the ball back to
facebook so facebook set up this
oversight board specifically to avoid
responsibility for these sorts of things
and then the oversight board was like
well you can't suspend trump
indefinitely so
we're gonna toss this back at you and in
six months or so you will reevaluate
whether trump ought to be put back on
the platforms now all of this
should frighten you because the reality
is that the rules are just an excuse
for facebook to kick off whoever they
want to youtube same sort of deal you
don't actually have to violate the rules
in order for public blowback to cause
youtube or facebook or twitter
to throw you off the internet this is
the real problem
and they like to say that all of this is
algorithmic and some of it is
algorithmic but somebody sets up the
algorithms and some of it is just not
algorithmic at all
when you make the decision to ban the
sitting presidents of the united states
from social media
that is not a decision that is being
made by a computer that is a decision
that is being made by high level people
at the companies in question
and in coordinated fashion i kind of
failed to see how it's not collusion in
fact to see all of the social media
companies all at once
decide to ban the presidents of the
united states the same way they did by
the way to alex jones or milo
yiannopoulos
doesn't mean i agree with a lot of the
things that are said by these folks but
the fact that social media have this
sort of top down control
is pretty astonishing now there's this
widespread perception out there and it's
a real misperception
that the left and the right agree on
this stuff they don't people on the
right are angry at big tech because they
believe that big tech has too much
control
over the dissemination of information
that big tech can be cudgelled and
bullied by the mainstream media
into basically shutting off all other
sources of information as i've discussed
before
the real threat to establishment media
is indeed social media and the reason
for that is because
with the rise of the internet you could
now go to places like fox news or daily
wire
if you wanted an alternative view of the
news or if you just wanted to hear news
from a conservative perspective or maybe
see news covered that the establishment
media wouldn't cover
and then because social media became so
big people started consuming their news
via social media right you used to go
directly to fox news or directly to
daily wire and now most people get their
news
by going to facebook and checking their
news feed well this
created a sort of uh almost a
sort of bottleneck in the pipeline for
informational flow and the establishment
media saw this they said oh look at that
isn't that interesting it used to be
that all information flowing out through
the internet through disparate means
you could go to this website here and
this website over there and it's very
difficult to shut that off but now if
everybody is getting their news through
facebook's news feed well what if we
just you know
took that bottleneck and just kind of
closed it what if we just made sure the
only things that could get through the
bottleneck
are the establishment media sources and
this is what the social media tech pros
have been going along with
they set up this measure at facebook for
what they called
sort of news news authoritativeness and
the way they ranked that was if you're
an establishment media source
then you are more authoritative and if
you are not an establishment media
source
you are not which of course the
conservatives is anathema because we
look at cnn and we say these people
report
fake news and fake narratives on a
fairly regular basis washington post
same thing new york times
same thing facebook has attempted to
sort of outs
they're constantly attempting to
outsource all of this to outside groups
so what they will do is they'll say well
you know
to determine which news is authoritative
we'll go to fact checkers
but then the fact checkers are all
left-wing fact-checkers it's like
politifact or snopes and
and all these folks are far to the left
and so facebook basically outsourced
its own perspective on free speech to a
bunch of outside leftist groups they
tried to do this with the facebook
oversight board
as well and the facebook oversight board
basically said look at that
facebook did the right thing in the
first place but at a certain point
they're going to have to determine
whether to permanently ban trump or not
okay so the left's perspective is that
the big problem with social media is
that too
much information is disseminated via
social media the rights perspective
is that too little information is
disseminated via social media
the right would prefer that there be a
broader range of
viewpoints that are allowed on social
media and the left would prefer as
always that only their viewpoint be
allowed
on social media and they have basically
cudgelled and bullied all of these
companies into mirroring that
perspective because if you look back at
the history of social media
if you look back at the statements made
by places like twitter and facebook when
they first started
their main mandate was we are going to
allow more people to speak
and then it became we are going to
better the conversation and by bettering
the conversation
they meant that they were going to work
on what you could see they were going to
make you a better person because
your bettors in silicon valley were
going to determine what you could and
could not see and so this is what you
see from the left today in the aftermath
of the news
that facebook is going to maintain that
ban on trump
the white house came out i mean this is
it's truly dystopian stuff
the white house came out and they said
you know what big tech companies should
go even further
they need to stop the misinformation now
this is really dangerous because the
white house you may have noticed is a
government agency
this is the executive branch of the most
powerful government world history
and the executive branch is saying we
want all of these social media companies
who are the chief mechanism by which
information is now disseminated
we want them actively to crack down on
things we deem
misinformation now it's important to
note here that the left has made a move
linguistically from disinformation to
misinformation you remember just a few
years ago 2016 there's a lot of talk
about russian disinformation
well the term disinformation has a
specific meaning disinformation means
a foreign government is putting out
false information in order to bamboozle
or hoodwink americans and pervert the
political process
that's what disinformation is and the
united states engages in
disinformation campaigns against foreign
regimes too right this is just something
that happens
in international politics and there's
certainly a strong case to be made
that if facebook knows that the russians
are disseminating disinformation
that they should shut that down it's a
foreign government attempting to affect
american elections for example
but there's a difference between
disinformation and misinformation by
shifting one letter
and conflating the two now you can just
declare anything you don't like
misinformation so hunter biden's story
maybe it's misinformation and this is
the way that the white house views this
sort of stuff
pointing out that joe biden's agenda is
extraordinarily radical
well that's that's misinformation we
can't allow that sort of misinformation
to thrive
even when people say things from an
american perspective right that are not
true
right if donald trump says that voter
fraud and regularity 100 decided the
election we wanted to land that kind of
stuff
even if that's not true to suggest that
that is akin to a russian source
promoting
active disinformation is not right i
mean donald trump does have a first
amendment right to say things
that are objectively untrue that that is
not banned by the first amendment
okay you you do have the right in the
united states to say things that
in your own viewpoint you think are true
even if they are not true and that holds
true on both sides but i've never called
for abram x kennedy who's a grifter
power excellence to be banned from
social media even though he routinely
says things that are wildly untrue
because that's fascistic you don't get
to use the means
of the government in order to push that
so what they've done is instead they've
shifted over the onus
to these corporations they're working
hand in glove with these corporations
and they're basically saying to the
corporations we'll leave you alone you
can have your monopoly
in fact we will we'll promote your
monopoly so long as you do
exactly what we want they've basically
turned these
corporations into agencies of the
federal government and then
used those corporations in order to shut
down the first amendment in a way they
could not do directly if the federal
government were to legislate
that information they don't like had to
be shut down by social media
that would be illegal if the federal
government threatens facebook
that they're going to regulate them in
some way if facebook does not do that
then the claim is that's not illegal
that's just good governance so here's
jen sackey from the white house saying
we hope that they
go further in fighting misinformation
the president's view
is that the major platforms
uh have a responsibility uh related to
the health and safety of all americans
uh to stop amplifying untrustworthy
content
disinformation and misinformation
especially related to covid19
vaccinations and elections and we've
seen that
over the past several months broadly
speaking i'm not placing any blame on
any individual or group we've seen it
from a number of sources
okay this is maddening and insane it's
maddening and insane for two reasons
which i'll get to in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that you don't want to go to the
post office i mean post office does a
lot of wonderful things but why would
you want to stand in line at the post
office schlep your packages over there
it's a pain in the butt
instead why not just do it from the
comfort of your own home this is why we
use stamps.com you don't have to go to
the post office anymore you can mail and
ship anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters
ship packages and pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups right to your computer
it's a must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
invoices at side hustle etsy shops
shipping out orders
or you're just navigating the current
hybrid worklife stamps.com can handle
all of it
with ease simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24 7 for any
letter any package any class mail
anywhere you want to send it when your
mail's ready
you just schedule a pickup or drop it
off and it is that simple you're done
with stamps.com you get discounts up to
40 percent off post office rates up to
off ups shipping rates you're saving
tons of time and tons of money stop
wasting your time going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no long
term commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that's
stamps.com promo code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again so you
have jen sackey saying that it's the
responsibility of these big tech
companies to quote unquote stop
misinformation number one that's just
not true
it's not true okay these big tech
companies are platforms the whole point
of them
is that it is not their job to police
what's in the comments section 230 of
the communications decency act was
specifically designed
to protect companies so that those
companies would not be held liable
legally for the stuff posted on their
website so now they're just reversing
this
right now they're going to say that
facebook ought to be held responsible
for stuff that a third party posts on
facebook which completely defeats the
purpose
of open threads it defeats the purpose
of comment sections it defeats the
purpose of youtube
and twitter and facebook it destroys
them wholesale if they are responsible
for the material
that appears on their platforms then
this means that they are effectively the
same as the new york times or the daily
wire they are just editorial sites
that's number one number two when she
says that we want them to crack down on
misinformation with regard to coveted
elections
let's just note here that the biden
administration has routinely lied about
both covenant and elections
the biden administration has suggested
over and over and over again
that georgia's new voter laws are jim
crow that is an overt lie it is an
abject disgusting overt lie
those laws are in many ways more
permissive with regard to voting than
for example new york
or new jersey there's no one who has a
shred of sanity who believes
that those laws look anything like jim
crow the great lie the democrats have
been promoting that voter suppression
has been deciding elections
it is a lie but they don't want that lie
shut down they want that lie promulgated
they want that lab promoted
they want it trumpeted from the highest
rooftop so they can pretend to black
americans
that the gop is trying to shut down
their rights
so those sorts of lies they want
promoted it just depends on the
misinformation and when it comes to
covid
i can't think of a bigger purveyor of
coven misinformation than this
administration
they keep just saying stupid crap that
makes no sense about masking
and outdoor standards and the efficacy
of the vaccines it's just ridiculous on
every level
but this is the the going push by the
folks
on the left the going pushes shut down
dissemination of information it's what
they want
this is authoritarian stuff yeah i have
a new book coming out called the
authoritarian moment it comes out in
july one of the things that i discuss
is one of the reasons that the left
wants to keep focusing on january 6th
because january 6 was really terrible it
was a terrible terrible event for the
country
but the reason they want to keep their
focus on january 6th is to
overlook the fact that the reaction to
january 6th on the left
is significantly more authoritarian than
the actual effect of january 6th
on january 6th a bunch of authoritarians
went in and tried to overturn the
legitimate results of an election
that's true and it was it was like
several hundred idiots and then they
were immediately cleared out and then a
bunch of republicans certified the
election
it was over the major institutions in
american life
the biggest most powerful institutions
in american life are attempting to
destroy your ability to disseminate
information
to see information they're attempting to
destroy your ability to raise your child
as you see fit
they're looking to destroy your business
if you fail to comply with their woke
standards
the authoritarian movement in the united
states is not chiefly from the right
this doesn't mean there aren't
authoritarians on the right there are
but the authoritarian movement in the
united states the dangerous
authoritarianism that we experience in
everyday life and at every level of
american society
is coming from the institutional heads
inside blue america
like i don't know what to say about the
fact that hillary clinton who is
secretary of state and senator from new
york and nearly the president of the
united states
she's out there saying yeah i know this
is great big tech needs to shut down
trump or
we should shut down big tech okay this
is just authoritarian stuff
there must be a reckoning by the tech
companies for
the role that they play in undermining
the information
ecosystem uh that is absolutely
essential for the functioning of
any democracy and it's going to be up to
governments
and i would even hope some global rules
but let's start with
governments to try to rein in uh the
disinformation
uh on the uh social media platforms
first of all that should scare the
living hell out of you when hillary
clinton and democrats start talking
about global governance
what we want zimbabwe's input and how
information gets disseminated this is
one of the big problems for facebook
facebook is a global company what they
should be doing is promulgating first
amendment american standards
they are not they are seeking explicitly
to have other governments regulate them
because they don't know what to do
because otherwise they're held liable
in places like germany for speech
they're not held liable for in places
like the united states so when you say
when hillary clinton says we need an
international global standard on free
speech
understand that's what we're talking
about here the idea that government's
job is to rein in the dissemination of
information
is precisely the reverse of the first
amendment it is precisely the opposite
of the first amendment
and the fact that they've gotten all
these social media companies to
basically do this stuff voluntarily
under threat
just demonstrates that essentially
they're using these major corporations
as their agents
and we are now operating not in a free
market capitalist america with regard to
social media we are operating in a
corporatist america with regard to
social
media where they are given special
privileges by the government and then
the government tells them
all you have to do is implement
standards that we like about information
that we don't like
adam schiff one of the great purveyors
of misinformation for years right i mean
this douchebag was on msnbc every single
day
talking about how the other shoe was
going to drop it was going to come out
that trump was
was actually peeing on russian
prostitutes or they were peeing on him
and
all of this was it was all russian
collusion the the evidence would show up
sooner or later
here is adam schiff saying that he hopes
that the ban from facebook is permanent
on trump
of course he does the president here is
continuing to go out and push the big
lie
about the election continuing i think to
to
endanger our democracy by doing that
and so he continues to make the case uh
that he would violate the policies
if they readmitted him and i think
frankly
pathologically he's incapable of
changing
so this is a temporary ban it will
likely be uh if we're fortunate a
permanent ban
because the president is not going to
stop the lies
about the last election or lies about
the next one he will incite people
i swear i don't want to hear about
authoritarianism from a group of people
who are using their perch in government
to attempt to literally stop a political
opponent from being able to speak
i mean that is the essence of
authoritarianism what you're watching
right now from the white house from
congress from hillary clinton
from this whole cadre of the mainstream
establishment left
is we want to use the methods of
informational dissemination to shut
down our political opponents and once
you threaten them to do it
we're going to threaten these companies
in order to make that happen and give
them special privileges and path them on
the head if they're good little boys and
girls
it's insanity but we're told that the
authoritarianism is on the right
the hell it is by the way not to be
self-serving here but the reality is
this is one of the reasons why you
should go subscribe to the services that
you love right now because at any moment
this entire tsunami of authoritarianism
nonsense
could be pushed against anybody
including places you like i could push
it against staley wire it could be
pushed against my show
go subscribe right now over at daily
wire because again you want to protect
the content that you love because i
don't trust these people do you
i don't trust these tech companies are
going to stand up to the overwhelming
tsunami of authoritarian nonsense being
pushed
by the establishment left if this is the
establishment left this is not
and it's amazing how fast the
liberal movement caved in the united
states to this this insane sensorius
left
how many liberals are left to stand up
to this how many liberals still stand
for the
original principles like the aclu how
many people still believe
i remember in the 90s people used to say
i'm left all the time this was their
their great
this was their great civil liberties
moment they would say things like
i may not agree with you but i will
defend to the death your right to say
what you want to say
right do you remember dissent as the
height of patriotism you remember this
during the iraq war
no longer now according to the
establishment left you disagree with us
and we will find a way to shut you down
including by the way the sitting
president of the united states at the
time we will find a way
to stop you from speaking and it would
be one thing if they had any sort of
articulable standard
that is consistently applied but there
is no articulable standard that's
consistently applied
the binding administration routinely
lies the binding administration
routinely
says things that are untrue democrats
members of the media have openly
defended
acts of violence depending on who is
committing the act of violence none of
them have been banned
so what this really is is just about
power it's so funny the entire
deconstructionist movement
this sort of philosophical
deconstructionist movement is about the
idea that there are no centralizing
principles everything is just a power
game
right then when people talk about
freedom and equality when people talk
about the principles of the declaration
of independence they're lying
that really all that was was a guise for
power it's all just a facade
right it's a way for rich white men to
cram down their own version of the
system
it's all projection okay
deconstructionism from the establishment
left is just product projection because
for them there are
no universal principles it is just about
power there are no universal principles
that apply to your rights there are no
universal principles that apply
to the level of misinformation that can
be disseminated there's nothing
consistent here it is just about what
they can get away with and what kind of
power they can use
in order to apply pressure that's all
and that's authoritarian there's no
other word for it
okay what we are watching right now
again this is not just a picture of my
book but it is a picture my book the
book the
is the authoritarian moment you can go
pre-order it right now on amazon because
i go through all of this in detail
they have renormalized america's
institutions in order to silence
everyone they disagree with and they are
doing it with big tech
right now and so for people on the right
who are like yeah there's a
wide right left agreement that we need
to shut down big tech no they disagree
for completely diff
they don't like big tech for completely
different reasons the right wants big
tech to consistently apply any standard
hopefully a very broad free speech
standard the left once you simply run
these companies
the left simply wants to make sure that
you cannot speak that you cannot share
that you are not allowed to to have
organic reach with the stories that you
push that you never see the information
they don't want you to see
most obvious example being that hunter
biden story the new york post
twitter account shut down a month before
the election because of a true hunter
biden story
facebook shutting it down preventing the
dissemination of even the link you
couldn't even link to it
and you watch this is the next move what
you will see is that now that donald
trump
has started his quasi blog on his page
the next move by twitter and facebook
will be
you are not allowed to tweet any link
from that blog
because again this is not about freedom
it is not about protecting democracy
these folks don't give a damn about
democracy are you kidding me
they want to completely rewrite the
rules of the game they want to
completely federalize every election
procedure in the united states they want
to make ballot harvesting legal
they want to make sure that voter id
cannot be put into law
and then they want to cram a bunch of
seats into the senate in undemocratic
fashion
in order to stack the system in favor of
their own political priorities they
don't give a damn about democracy or the
procedures of the constitution
it's all just a power game in the end
it's all about power for the
establishment left there are
no principles if you are if you're a
believer that there are principles from
the same people who are saying that
misinformation has to be shut down on
the internet but we can lie as much as
we want
i don't know what to tell you they are
unprincipled it is just power
we'll get to all of this with regard to
covet because that is 100 truth covered
in just one second first let's talk
about something that is just awesome so
over the couch in my house i have a
beautiful portrait of me
and my wife and two of my kids we're
going to order a new one with all three
of my babies who are just gorgeous from
one of the great services ever i'm
talking about
paintyourlife.com this makes a great
mother's day gift by the way get a
professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price
choose from a team of world-class
artists work with them until every
detail is perfect
user-friendly platforms lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
it's a quick and easy process you can
send any picture yourself your kids
family special place cherished pet or
this is really cool you can combine
photos in one painting so you couldn't
have your sister
for a particular event so you just kind
of photoshop her in there they can do
that
for you it makes the perfect birthday
anniversary wedding mother's day gift
it's a meaningful personal gift it can
be cherished forever
right now go check out paintyourlife.com
it really is
super cool to get their special offer
right now as a limited time offer you
get 20
off your painting 20 off and free
shipping to get that offer text the word
ben
to 64 000. that has been do 64 000 text
to 64 000. paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most
terms apply available at painterlife.com
again
text ben to 64 000 go check them out
right now and again there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed it's
awesome 20 off check them out text ben
64 000 to get started
alrighty so when it comes to
dissemination of information
for misinformation for political
purposes this white house
has no problem doing that not in the
slightest so
the entire administration approach to
covid and vaccines and masking is absurd
it's absurd on its face
we have now run into what people are
calling the demand wall with regard to
vaccination
what that means is that there's way more
supply than demand
right there's a lot of supply the supply
was ramped up by trump
okay biden continued that biden is the
luckiest man ever to be elected
president not only because he's not
sentient
but also because he inherited an entire
vaccination program
an entire rollout program and then he
gets credit for it okay so in any case
a huge number of americans have already
been vaccinated right now we are going
from like three million vaccinations a
day down to like one million why well
number one the people who wanted it the
most already went and got it
and number two they're now running into
what's called the demand wall one of the
reasons for the demand wall the reason
that people
are not out there clamoring for the
vaccine is because if you are vaccine
hesitant there is no incentive being
promoted by this administration
to get the vaccine like none they're not
telling you you can go back to regular
life which you can scientifically
speaking
okay they're not telling you that after
you get that second vaccine dose and
you're two weeks out you can unmask
which again the data supports that you
can do this
i i name a single study one study that's
all i ask one study demonstrating
that the vaccinated are passing this
virus in any significant numbers
there are no studies to support that i
mean zero and the administration admits
this by the way
the administration will openly admit
that they're just doing this
mainly out of a sense of virtue
signaling but they continue to promote
it promote it anyway
so they're promoting all sorts of just
untruth and garbage
about the about their standards okay so
their standards with regard to for
example summer camps are absurd
they're absurd on their face philip
kline writes for
the national review so
the the standards themselves are just
ridiculous the standards are like
kids have to wear masks outdoors so you
don't have to wear a mask outdoors
but only if you're vaccinated which is
ridiculous
there's no reason to be wearing a mask
outdoors if you're distance from other
people
and kids masking outdoors is absurd in
the first place
okay like the kids are not passing this
in vast numbers kids are not
affected as a general rule harshly by
covet the number of kids who have died
from covet is still under 300
in a nation of 330 million people say
anthony fauci for example was asked
about the summer camp standards
and he can't even defend it it doesn't
make any sense here's anthony fauci
again how this guy became the most
trusted doctor in america or second most
trusted after dr jill biden the greatest
of all doctors
is beyond me because he's conflicted
himself one thousand times
he has lied about things he's openly
admitted that he has lied about things
he's terrible at his job he needs to go
but here he is promulgating standards on
summer camps that make no sense at all
you know i wouldn't call them excessive
uh savannah but i
they certainly are conservative and i
think what you're gonna start to see is
really in real time
continually re-evaluating that for its
practicality
because you're right people look at that
and they say well
is that being a little bit too far right
now yeah because aren't we supposed to
be
we've been told people have been
preaching for a year follow the science
the science doesn't suggest those cdc
guidelines are too sensible for
little kids outside in 90 degree heat
running around with masks
yes somebody you've asked me that
question a couple of times before
[Laughter]
but do it i'm sorry this is a joke it's
a joke even
fouchy can't offend it right these are
absurd guidelines they say vaccinated
adults and children have to wear masks
outdoors
unless they are eating drinking or
swimming it's just
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous on its
face and fouchy is asked about he has no
answer for it he laughs it off
are you still rachelle willenski of the
cdc who again should also be fired
terrible at her job
michelle wolenski you remember just a
few weeks ago she's saying i have a
feeling of impending doom
it feels in my in my heart like there's
like joom is coming and i said at the
time there's no evidence doom is coming
like give me some scientific data the
doom is coming why the hell do i care
about rachelle wolensky's
interior feelings oh my god she feels
like doom is coming yeah so did
nostradamus it's been a while
but it's but again the idea that she is
this administration promulgates lies
about covet
lies about kovid here she is saying that
heavily breathing kids playing soccer
should mask outside i'm sorry this is
absurd
you know i think not all outside is is
um
the same so outside playing tennis
outside um
swimming all of those things where
you're far apart from one another if you
have a group of ten-year-olds crowded
trying to get over a soccer ball
and they're all breathing heavily i
think you need to wear a mask because
yes
you there's decreased infection risk
outside
but if you're all breathing heavily on
top of a singular soccer ball
um that has the potential and we've seen
a lot of outbreaks associated with youth
sports
these are the same people who said
during the entire george floyd summer
that dancing outside and twerking in
large groups was totally fine
remember in arlington texas they just
had opening day
40 000 people were crammed into a
stadium outdoors no outbreak
none can the data to support these
standards are non-exi
like there are no data to support the
standards which is why rachel lenski has
asked about the standards and she can't
even explain them
right she was asked on cnn good for cnn
she was asked
you know why are vaccinated people being
told they need a mask inside like
they're fine
we have over 87 million people in the
united states who have been double
vaxxed at this point
or single vacs with johnson and johnson
and the grand number of people
grand total number of people last i
checked which was like three days ago
who had died of kovid after being fully
vaxxed was 88
in other words your chances of dying
from cove after being vector like one in
a million
literally one million so willenski is
asked
why are you telling vast people to mask
inside she has no answer to this because
there is no reason
this isn't the science this is just a
bunch of horse
we're asking that people who are
vaccinated remain uh remain
in masks when they're indoors indoors
when they're indoors well but you know
but if i'm working if i'm working with a
butt you know if i'm working with
everyone in my office is also vaccinated
why so i was going to say indoors and
really in public settings so
you know in our private settings
guidance we say if you know
for certain that everyone around you has
been vaccinated they're not at risk of
they have no
um high-risk people in their in their
households then we say in those settings
that you could take off your math
okay so she can't even answer the
question and by the way let's be real
about this if you're vaccinated
and you are in a room with a person who
has coveted you will be
fine the data know this the whole
purpose of the code of vaccine is to
make you fine
the reality is these vaccines are
extraordinarily effective
like insanely effective and you have
this entire administration downplaying
the efficacy of the vaccines by the way
you know who says that if you're sitting
in a room with a person with covet and
you have the vaccine you're fine
the cdc because none of their standards
make any sense they say that if you are
in a room
unmasked with a person with covid and
you have
had the vaccines you don't have to
quarantine unless you become symptomatic
so they're not worried about you
asymptomatically passing this thing
they're just
lying to you okay but don't worry
they're going to be the police on
misinformation
and and the arrogance with which they
spout this crap is just
insane right kamala harris the
co-president of the united states she
was asked about ron desantis so random
ron desantis who actually analyzes the
data and you know has presided over the
great success story in america it really
is
you know when people it's amazing to me
people be like you know california and
florida they have very similar death
rates and they took opposite views
they don't have similar death rates
because the thing you have to remember
is that florida has the second oldest
population in america after maine
and maine has like seven people and a
beaver okay
florida has 21 million people it has by
far the oldest population in america
california has like the third youngest
population in america so if you have two
states one of which has a very young
population and one of
which has a very old population and
their deaths per million ratio is the
same
you know what that means it means the
person who ran the old population state
did a fantastic job
okay but still this administration is
going to claim that ronda sanchez
doesn't know what he's doing because ron
desantis put out
an order that you would that there are
no more locally justified mass mandates
you said if you're a business and you
want to have a mass mandate
that's your problem you're a private
business you can do what you want but no
local mass mandates correct because
there's no data to support local mass
mandates
at this point in time in florida but
here's kamala hair saying we have to
follow the experts let's follow the
experts
governor defenses in florida has made
has rolled back the ability of
cities and local governments to enforce
their own covenant restrictions do you
believe that that is a mistake is that
super premature at this point with the
pandemic
i strongly believe that whatever rules
protocols and procedures are put in
place must be guided by the public
health experts
period okay so again follow the public
health experts so let
me show you what kamala harris does to
follow the public health experts
yesterday
she was walking to her car with her
husband douglas hemhoff
and uh they had this very romantic
moment
and they're walking they're walking and
as they're about
to part they lean forward they're both
masked and they kiss through the mask
what is this eyes wide
shut and what the hell is that
is that what the is that what the cdc is
that what the health experts are saying
then that you you kiss your spouse you
have to wear a mask also
it's like that scene from naked gun
where they're completely covered top to
bottom in condoms and making out like
what in the world is this these are our
health experts these are the people
you're supposed to trust
about covered misinformation okay
there's a reality it's why they're
again there's no science to this it's
ridiculous i'm sorry this is ridiculous
what
there's no science to suggest that when
you kiss your spouse you're supposed to
both be wearing masks
outdoors the hell what what
then you have mayor muriel bowser of dc
who has turned into john lithgow from
footloose
she is now telling people there will be
no dancing because
twerking might lead to dancing like what
here here's muriel bowser explaining
even after
mass vaccination of the dc population
she may not
green light dancing at weddings she's
like you should just be glad we allow
you to have weddings in washington dc
authoritarian crap here she is mayor
just just is there any way that you
would reconsider with masks on
and say a card that shows fully
vaccinated that you'd allow dancing
we're absolutely considering opening
more activity
as our case rates go down and our
vaccination rates go up
and that's in our hotels uh and that's
in our other venues
now so banning the dancing this is the
democratic party they've actually become
the puritans they are masked puritans at
this point
there's a reason for this the reason for
this is not just because of their simple
paranoia about the virus although this
has become a sort of virtue signaling
lifestyle choice for a lot of democrats
at this point
it's not about the health it's not about
preventing the spread of covet it's
about i'm a better person than you
because i wear a mask
just like everything else in american
life this is broken down into virtue
signaling horse nonsense
okay so in a second i'll explain what
really is backing this for the political
actors
and not for the common everyday democrat
who's decided they're better than you
because they're
wearing triple masks and a bag around
their head with duct tape around their
neck for the rest of time
but why exactly your political branches
are pushing this we'll get to that in
just
one second first if 2020 taught us
anything now is an excellent time to get
prepared make sure your family will have
food in times of need
remember empty grocery store aisles are
not just associated with pandemic
if there's an earthquake or if there is
any sort of natural disaster you know
people run out to the grocery store and
they buy what they need and then you
might get caught up
short the supply chain is fragile food
prices are continuing to increase
take control of tomorrow make sure your
family is ready with plenty of reliable
nutritional meals for when it matters
most you shouldn't have to sacrifice
taste and nutrition with emergency food
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
and
latest food preparation technology to
ensure optimal taste
and freshness ready wise is the leader
in emergency food supplies they make
being prepared simple
and affordable their delicious meals
have up to a 25-year shelf life they are
simple to make
just add some water order online have
emergency food and your food
gets shipped directly to your doorstep
again
everybody recommends that you have at
least some emergency food supplies in
your home it's just the responsible
thing to do particularly if you have
kids readywise is offering exclusive
pricing for my listeners today
visit readywise.com shapiro save up to
off emergency food and supplies that's
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-com
shapiro for exclusive pricing go check
them out right now alrighty
we're going to get to the actual agenda
behind so much of this
actual misinformation being put out by
the political branches of our government
and the media in just one second first
as you know daily water has been growing
like crazy
like we've been growing aton so we have
a movie deal with gina carano we
released our first feature film we
launched a new talk show hosted by
candace owens we release debunked we
have all
this stuff and it's all happened within
the last like five months well
we moved our entire company like we have
a bunch of big plans for you
and i'm excited to tell you about them
and i'm excited to thank you for that
because honestly we couldn't grow the
way that we have without your help
and we want to continue to include you
in our future plans so you know every
day on the show i talk about a lot of
amazing products and services from the
sponsors
that i love and use and that you guys
love and use but we want to get to know
you better
so we can choose our sponsors with you
in mind so we can make sure they are
successful and you get what you need
so please head on over to dailywire.com
fill out my audience survey
tell us a little bit more about yourself
and to sweeten the whole experience
those of you who complete the survey
will be entered to win one thousand
dollar gift card
you can only take the survey once per
daily wire show so if you want to
increase your chances of winning a
thousand bucks
go listen to michael knowles andrew
claven or matt walsh get access to their
surveys as well again
the survey link is dailywire.com
we would love to hear from you
also if you haven't already joined daily
wire you should do it right now today
is your last chance to get 25 off
a new membership with code candidates at
dailywire.com subscribe
if you didn't catch tuesday's episode of
candace don't worry her full interview
with president trump
is available to all daily wire members
they discuss everything from big tech
censorship to the media's impact on his
family
and even they get into the possibility
of trump owens
2024. you've already seen the headlines
go check out the full interview
this is your final reminder to get 25
off a new membership with code kansas at
dailywire.com
subscribe that's right tomorrow you'll
have to get your membership at full
price so like now is your last chance
sign up today save 25
off with code canvas at dailywire.com
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so what is the actual agenda
here the actual agenda of course
is to grow the government right if you
can continue to promote the idea
that america is in a state of crisis and
that everybody has to mask up
and that nobody's going back to work
then you can continue to promote these
giant government programs
so democrats right now are continuing to
promote the idea of a national
eviction moratorium okay here's the deal
america's unemployment rate is down back
to like six percent
it is we're adding jobs hand over foot
the only reason
handover fist the only reason why we
have not added more jobs is because we
have paid people to stay home
right now small businesses are having
trouble getting people to actually come
in and work
because there are so many people who are
making more money by being on
unemployment
okay so the job but democrats don't want
to accept that we are back in an upward
economic swing
number one because they want to take
credit for it with stimulus that has not
yet even gone out
and number two because they want to
promote the idea that the pandemic
continues so they can continue to ram
through trillions upon trillions of
dollars
in spending so let's be real about this
in the first place the federal
government did not have the ability to
simply declare via executive fiat and
eviction moratorium
the cdc does not have the power to
simply declare across the nation
the center for disease control are the
center for rent like what
where's the empowering legislation that
allows the cdc to decide that you no
longer
have to pay rent and by the way who
exactly compensates the landlords
you know you talk about these housing
shortages in america's major cities it
turns out
when you deprive landlords of rent for
like a year the predictable response is
i'm not going to
build any more buildings and rent them
out you end up with more of a shortage
like rent control
the more you prevent the free market
from having its way the more you prevent
supply from meeting demand
okay in any case a federal judge in
washington dc on wednesday according to
the washington post ruled that the
center for disease control and
prevention overstepped its legal
authority by issuing a nationwide
eviction moratorium
a ruling that could affect millions of
struggling americans well
yeah but that's not like if congress
wants to pass an eviction moratorium
they can go ahead and try first of all i
think that's probably unconstitutional
it violates the
the freedom of contract that is inherent
in in freedom of association in the
united states but
since we long ago gave up on anything
like limited government
i suppose that you could try to pass
that via congress the idea that the cdc
unilaterally gets to decide that you
don't have to pay a rent anymore is it
an absurdity on its face
the order says it is the role of the
political branches and not the courts to
assess the merits of policy measures
designed to combat the spread of disease
even during a global pandemic the
question for the court is a narrow one
does the public health service act grant
the cdc the legal authority to impose a
nationwide eviction moratorium
it does not the biden administration
says it will appeal the decision
so here's the thing why what's the end
of the pandemic what are you appealing
the ruling does not affect state or
local eviction moratoriums in washington
dc for example the city government's ban
on all evictions
remains in place landlords and property
owners have consistently challenged the
cdc order
arguing the policy sets an undue
financial burden on business owners yeah
you think
it turns out that if you run an
apartment complex and you can't evict
anybody for not paying their bills
you're the one who ends up footing the
bill for that
okay and they want to continue this like
indefinitely they want to continue these
eviction moratoriums
the question at this point is not even
the legal authority to do this the
question at this point is
why are you even pushing eviction
moratoriums when we are at the end of
the pandemic
and the answer is they want a forever
pandemic folks on the democratic side of
the aisle want a forever pandemic
because
every crisis is an opportunity so we're
going to promote bad scientific
standards with regard
to the with regard to covid we are going
to
promote endless spending because covet
is still a crisis
right this is why you have the entire
democratic party still promoting
the idea that we need to spend tons and
tons and tons of money on infrastructure
okay let's be straight about this the
united states does not have a major
infrastructure problem the brookings
institute
says and has been saying for years the
united states our infrastructure is
actually in pretty good shape this ain't
about infrastructure it's about
everything
if you can call it infrastructure it
becomes infrastructure here is
co-president harris yesterday
suggesting that infrastructure is child
care
i'd like to hear from each of you as
though you are talking to the people in
washington dc
to explain why
child care is part of infrastructure and
let me just tell you the way i define
infrastructure one of my definitions
is the things you just need to get where
you need to go
so let's talk about why child
care is a part of that
i define infrastructure as anything i
want anytime i want it
so let's talk about why free ice cream
is infrastructure
okay this is why they need the pandemic
because otherwise everybody would look
at this and go are you insane
healthcare is not infrastructure you
want to do something on healthcare try
it
you want to call it infrastructure
you're out of your damn mind
but the entire democratic party is into
this because of course they don't care
about deficits
alexander ocasio-cortez she's out there
this is this genius this economic genius
democrat twitch she says but you know
we keep worrying about deficits why are
we even worrying about deficits i mean
i've never had to actually meet a
payroll but
sure i know how to spend your money i
don't think that the deficit is the most
important
thing uh upon which we should be
hinging the our infrastructure and jobs
plan on
i think um it's not the deficit it's
things like employment it's things like
our
poverty rate in the united states or
rather unemployment as well
it's we should be pegging this to
the actual material circumstances
uh that we want to measure ourselves
against
in improving people's lot uh in this
country that's a long way of saying i
don't want to pay for anything because i
don't need to pay for anything because
i've never paid for anything
so that's a really easy way of doing
that really well done right there
joe biden also defending his massive
spending plans in his typically
incoherent fashion
everything i'm proposing
that be done to generate economic growth
employment
and uh put us in a position where we can
out-compete any other country in the
world with research and development
and moving ahead um i pay for
we talk about i love we talk about how
this is going to cost so much money i'm
not paying for it
i mean he's a joke by the way he says
he's pushing higher taxes
the language he uses with regard to
higher taxes is so patently crazy
he says things like well you know i'm
just you know those rich people
they just don't need that second and
third house first of all talk to bernie
he seems to like that lake house an
awful lot you seem to like your multiple
houses an awful lot mr president
but beyond that that's not the question
the question is whether you confiscate
wealth from the people who have
typically created jobs and hand it to a
bunch of dufy
over at the federal government to decide
how exactly to disseminate that wealth
in the most inefficient possible fashion
or whether you allow the economy to grow
but for him it's all about confiscation
of wealth the real motivating factor
here is that joe biden wants to go down
in history as not an inconsequential
figure that's all
joe biden knows he's a one-term guy he's
clearly a one-time guy
and because he's a one-term guy he wants
to just push everything through
right now and he's got the pandemic to
bangkong and that pandemic is on the way
and it's pretty much at the end of it i
mean we know we all know this
contra anthony fauci who says we're in
the bottom of the six which is just nuts
we are nearing the end of this thing and
everyone is aware of this
joe biden is using that as the basis for
the argument that we are just going to
penalize because he knows then
the beautiful thing about being a
democrat is you can be the crappiest
president ever you can be just garbage
and they will continue to
to laud you as an amazingly
transformational figure so long as you
grew the government it doesn't matter
that fdr's
programs expanded the great depression
into a decade-long event
it does not matter because he grew the
government it doesn't matter that lbj's
economic program
took a very strong economy circle like
1963-1964 and proceeded to transform it
into a stagnating government a
stagnating economy
all the way from 1967 essentially to
1981.
okay that's okay because he grew the
government joe biden knows the same he
knows that history will judge him by how
much he grew the government
not how well the economy did under his
term right because
if you think of historic american
democratic presidents nobody thinks of
bill clinton
even though the economy did great under
bill clinton everybody thinks instead
of who grew the government most joe
biden knows this and that's why he's
pushing this nonsense and that's also
why he's pushing his
class warrior nonsense pretty ironic
stuff from a guy who allowed his son to
run around
the globe picking up bags of cash using
his last name
we're not going to deprive any
executives their second or third home
travel privately by jet that's not going
to affect their standard living
at all not a little tiny bit
but i can affect the standard living the
people i grew up with
if they have a job i can expect to
make sure the standard of living and
people i grew up with
child care can afford it so 20 million
women can be back in the workforce
i can affect the standard relationship
with the amazon grew up with
this incoherent old daughter talking
about how
you know if he confiscates wealth from
the wealthy and then he gives it to
people at the other end of the spectrum
this is going to create jobs
yeah you know they've tried this in many
many places it does not create economic
growth it is a dumb
idea it has been disproved every time it
has been tried but you need the pandemic
in order to push this sort of stuff
you need it because if we went right
back to that three percent unemployment
rate we had under trump
everybody recognizes you don't need to
do what the democrats are talking about
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of
content coming up soon the matt wall
show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you